the program of 1938 remembrance and
reconciliation in the interview chief
rabbi of Moscow pinches Goldschmidt ravi
nagesh madonna by Goldschmidt it's been
75 years since the night of broken glass
the lights pogum knocked as it's
officially called in Germany you know
you know this will also be the first
time since the Second World War that
European rabbis will meet in Berlin was
it a difficult decision to make given
the gravity of that fateful point in
history for yon else mr. conference up
years ago our standing committee agreed
to meet his Merlin searched on come and
at that time the big question was
whether or not the entire conference
might return to germinate when we can
the conclusion Jewish community is now
existing and driving in Germany
especially since some 150,000 jews love
who emigrate here from the former Soviet
Union hundred fifty thousand you
wouldn't fund the ex-soviet Union here I
advances in so there really was no
question about it the Germans jewelry is
part of european jewry as a home to him
via globe none it's our mission to renew
and rebuild Jewish life here in Germany
guns Europa since the showa that we've
been of committed to that tab throughout
Europe he's from the admit ow the
Swedish living here in deutschland vida
out spell the tie step and you're saying
there was no resistance among European
rabbis to meeting here precisely under
75th anniversary you know people help me
no there was absolutely no dissenting
they keep it going hottest what meaning
does the conference in Berlin have for
european jews v this is an paradox to
Atlantis hoy to the sign it's a paradox
Germany is the only European country
where the jewish population is actually
increasing you should get mine decliner
in most other countries the numbers are
sinking on the jewish community here is
very young and not
very well organized new let's see it's
taken some time because the majority
here are from the Soviet Union is yet
they had no chance at all organized in
their homeland even they couldn't raise
their children in the face there was no
schooling in line with Jewish principal
to help kinda mindedly so it's important
for us to be in Berlin and aud sheets
you and to underscore our effort is to
rebuild a vibrant jewish community in
Germany in Berlin Suzanne Suzanne via
Mohammed and these are on vida of Bao
anh anh that su comfed and students here
in deutschland z-bone as you that means
that Jewish life in Germany is depend on
those who could not live their faith in
the Soviet Union windows a bit only one
exactly is that difficult as is the
Swedish a vanished one very difficult
but not impossible in mutant força you
know that the Jewish people have always
had to face difficult struggles VF it's
5,000 Java we didn't have our own nation
for over 2,000 years went at avaya and
three years after the end of the
Holocaust it'll show Holocaust the
darkest chapter our history choix the
Jewish people were allowed to return to
Jerusalem and Israel mint on the legacy
sh t we never gave up hope this is you
do [ __ ] although in 1945 you many Jews
thought the end had come his way though
we had needed hosting for long nachman
film fetish Kappa see you wouldnt the
grout and the sisters and Ribena go to
meet with in chemspider by Goldschmidt
we're in the dining room of what used to
be a private synagogue Beth Zion
leadership you say that Jewish life is
possible and that's an opinion many
people appear to share you predict a
renaissance of German Judaism push one
Android to the same degree as that which
influence and impacted Germany in a
myriad of ways over five six and seven
decades and frozen behind worked on the
symbiosis tuition
a su shun des deutschen cultura the
symbiosis between German culture and the
Jewish minority is embedded into the
history of the past century yahoo nuts
Galip taught when the voices the course
presents fun german jews have played a
magnificent role in german literature
and the culture as a whole akuto eval
the system this is natalia sheesh day
one and of course before World War two
berlin was a recognized center of Jewish
thought and knowledge for rabbis this
yudish envisions the fuel of abena Vicki
relief speeding what role does modern
Germany play with its soul searching
about the Holocaust who are the MU la
kasbah fith what do jews in europe and
around the world think of this like to
go for the UN individuality and norfolk
studland meet Chancellor Adenauer on
speedometer under in console idea not
him coming on her to alchemy there's a
common consensus that Germany has a
special duty since this was true from
the post-war period under chancellor
konrad adenauer and with all other
Chancellor's including Angela Merkel the
flesh does translate Germany has pledged
to do all it can to protect the State of
Israel from its enemies and to support
the recreation of a vital Jewish
community here in Germany he recognized
the Incan and sweatin so this vida a few
months ago we awarded Chancellor
Merkel's feet of the Lord jacobowitz
prize at a ceremony in Brussels via
Robin for I'm pomona t'en the Chancellor
Angela Merkel then it was our way of
thanking earth for her tireless efforts
on behalf of European jewelry and
against anti-semitism on yo on gosh more
she also mediated in the recent
controversy over circumcision in Germany
anti-semitism or or lessons ow the end
child the wall a vent bushnell onix the
party he and Deutsche and FEMA this
anti-semitism is a recurring concern it
was the do you see reason for concern
here in Germany anti-semitism assist I
Knievel's this issue entered on vac suit
in the anti-semitism is a virus that
mutates and grows in mittelalter as Papa
religiosa bad anti-semitism ooze in the
Middle Ages Europe was very religious so
religion took on anti-semitic overtones
would the anti-semitism now Europe is
more secular and as a result
anti-semitism is more racist in nature
that israel tonge east after the State
of Israel was founded that's
anti-semitism took on anti Zionist he
was hunting plots from from traditional
anti-semitism asst genome be having it
songstress gets me to meet now there's
increased concern about the circumcision
decisions wind whistles Kazak in
Brussels Chancellor Merkel commented
that much of the commentary on the issue
was racist and anti-semitic abysus Gavin
feel it we fear this might be the new
face of anti-semitism loughton went via
hardened angst us thus finished de nguoi
em was no use East this modern
anti-semitism assist the sizes you
wouldn't do you mean that Jews are
concerned about whether they can carry
out the religious traditions can now buy
london Wharton and the circumcision is a
basic tenant of the Jewish faith I mean
anyone wanting to convert must submit to
this procedure yet at the mutant as you
know Hanukkah begins in a few weeks time
what's this about the same period as
your Christmas holidays
thus it commemorates the Maccabean
revolt against greek occupation that's
of the clay and the Greek ban on
circumcision and D rivoluzione London
maccabiah gigging tasik vicious degree
show occupation vivienda support the
devotion item once it is Nia out dust
Alton um if you're also surely aware
that the old term for new year in both
the Anglican and Greek Orthodox churches
honored the circumcision of Jesus Europe
is becoming a secular society above it
Europe is grappling with immigrants from
the Middle East and northern Africa and
wonderful but curbing religious freedoms
would be the wrong path or a pluralistic
uris TV crime I in pluralistic oppa East
the really big uns thigh height and
strengthen get this i need our European
rabbis concerned about any one country
in particular right now is though in
these inside the cooking the st.
Vincent's ish observed from m.d were
certainly disturbed at the rise of
neo-fascist parties in Hungary and the
extreme right in Greece on the financial
crisis has brought many dark
undercurrents to the surface the finance
Kleiza Europe must fight against these
powers to ensure that the past doesn't
repeat itself get off on the own papa
Muskegon Giza these a crafter come from
whom this design does the fig and how it
needs to be the whole trip robina
Goldschmidt rabbi Goldschmidt what
message would this conference try to
send to Germany anti Europe of not
dawdlin teens in the signal veredus in
essence
the night of broken glass occurred 75
years ago stunna the top in my mind that
was the starting point for the final
solution on Holocaust the end Luke
that's other something from whole lot we
survived and the Senate Jewish faith is
vibrant once again throughout Europe de
su Luke the student to miss Edith
Judaism has also returned to Germany and
we hope this country will continue to
commit itself to seeing that it never
happens again touch-tones via Alejandra
that goes for all countries who
contributed to the Holocaust cosmic
Komaki the conflict cost 80 million
lives in Europe so I like it must never
be repeated the amended if Jews may have
been the first victims but in the end
all of Europe suffered under the Nazi
RGH Ravana fleshly estaba about my in
the valley de oil appear and offer thus
Nazi regimes raveena grab I go to me
thank he is good week position